[Music]
no more Petro is the slogan
demonstrators repeated over and over as
they March through downtown Bogota
protesting against the social and
economic reforms proposed by Colombia's
first ever leftist president
policies Gustavo Petro says will fix
Decades of Injustice and inequality but
that opposers argue will only worsen
Colombia's plight
we oppose a reform that will destroy our
health system pretending that it doesn't
work when it does a president who wants
to give the health money to Mayors and
governors all to satisfy his populist
ideas
the march called by the right-wing
Democratic Center party of former
president Alvar Uribe were the largest
organized by the opposition since Petro
took office in August and they came just
a day after supporters of the government
took to the streets to support the
reforms among them a controversial
Health bill that would end private
management of Health funds while
promising to increase coverage and
access
El Cambio a Reform Bill that will now
start what promises to be a torturous
approval process in Congress where it
will likely face changes
these rallies are a message for Petra
the streets are speaking up saying that
the reforms he wants to impose on us
will not pass and that Congress has to
listen to us as well
the government's opponents Define
themselves as Patriots and saviors of a
country they fear could slide away from
democracy
some flu that don't tread on me flag
used by Donald Trump supporters in the
U.S
confrontation came along the Route when
the most radical protesters met Petra
supporters
we're just faced off against a group of
leftist indigenous teachers from the
kalka region in Southwest Colombia were
sheer to protest against the current
health system
in Colombia's Second City Medellin
protesters clashed with the police as
they tried to enter the office of the
mayor a pitcher supporter
either smashed a copy of the peace style
sculpture every known Colombian painter
Fernando botero created in response to
the 2016 peace process with farc Rebels
but despite these incidents both the
government and opposition rallies have
been largely peaceful considered by many
to be a good sign in a country long
defined by political violence and still
learning to negotiate its differences
peacefully Alessandra Al Jazeera Bogota